all right welcome to the last part of
the last session oh I guess the first
part of the last part of the last
session of uh Tony Cs and uh it's my
pleasure to introduce uh architect
Institute for fundamental research
thanks thank you yeah uh it's uh so nice
to be here uh well I remember there was
this Workshop going on in the fields and
uh I won't name the persons some
Professor from McGill came up and said
so this is Tony patasi your uh post
documenter and what what's her age and
uh I said well I I guess it must be
around 50 so that's like 10 years ago
and you know he said well I must be
lying he just doesn't look uh 50. so
anyway it's nice to have a 60th birthday
celebration
so uh it's a little change of plans uh
I'm not exactly sticking to the title
sorry for that so this talk uh is based
on joint Works which a lot of people uh
yogesh dahiya whose last name I have
misspelled so if he's watching I'm
really I really apologize
so as uh in many of my or most of my
work these days The Story begins with
some paper of Tony which is always a
starting point so here as well it is the
case so this is this paper that she has
with Shafi goldwasser raso and Rahul
so this paper is about the
pseudo-deterministic query model
and I'll tell you in a moment what it is
it's a very natural model for defining
randomized randomized algorithms in the
context of search problems
and uh what these people do is they
prove a separation between randomized
query and pseudo deterministic query in
particular
they show that there's a very natural
search problem namely the random random
CNF formula which is a tfnp search
problem which has randomized query
complexity order one that sort of
obvious but the non-trivial quite
non-trivial part is that this received
or deterministic query takes
Omega root n many queries so this gives
an exponential separation uh for the
between randomized query and pseudo
deterministic query
mm-hmm
so they asked two challenging questions
and these were one the ones that really
inspired yogesh uh who was the one who
got us all together and these two
questions were the following improve
this separation to uh you know an order
one versus Omega n and I think this is
still open probably Rahul is going to
talk a bit about that after my talk
and the one that I was really interested
in is to lift this separation in the
context of communication complexity uh
which is
um you know you same question now the
model is two-party communication show a
separation for a search problem uh in
tfnp ideally uh which has order one or
you know small poly log randomized uh
cost but every pseudo deterministic
communication protocol would require
polynomial costs okay
I'm sorry I lost the very beginning
what is it a random CNN total function
and research program oh sorry so for
every CNF so if you take a random CNF
it's with high probability and
satisfiable and so we'll look at this
the search problem corresponding to
given an assignment find a falsified
Clause okay that's what it is
foreign
okay
so these were the challenging questions
and uh you know yogesh and us we thought
a lot so this was the early day so it
was just yogesh me and Meena and we
couldn't
you know do either of them
so I had to remind uh Mina and yogesh
that you know Tony loves to ask a really
challenging and hard problems so it's
not going to be easy and meanwhile later
on Tony told me over Zoom that I
shouldn't feel so bad because she is
still working on this problem and very
actively and you know the problem hasn't
yielded
so at this point
we said let's change gears let's make
consider some intermediate models so I
was mainly interested in the
communication complexity as I said since
we couldn't prove anything there well we
said let's look at some intermediate
models namely these things and or
decision tree or parity decision tree
and let us see if we can prove similar
separations like they have in these
models
yes I am going to Define yeah
can you say whether
[Music]
right one or not that's what the
conjecture that random format yeah I
think that's a second
okay so I'll start defining things a
little bit more so that Things become a
little clearer so this is something I
really don't have to Define but uh let's
just slowly uh go through this so you
know I'm going to now consider although
I will talk about search problems this
whole talk would be sort of converting a
search problem into a problem about
Boolean functions and then doing things
over there so these are some well-known
Boolean functions or and parity indexing
here this is an orbit indexing and here
are some decision trees sort of
canonical decision trees for these
functions and uh what we would be
interested here is for example if you
look at the and function the depth is n
you can't do any better if you want to
compute the or function you require
depth n that's uh simple to verify via
an adversarial argument
but the size is n Plus 1. and I will
talk a lot about size so size n plus 1
is sort of very economical here so it's
a very skinny tree the size for a height
entry could be two to the N but instead
it's just n plus one okay
so these are two measures size and depth
size has received less attention depth
has received somehow more attention in
the case of parity this seems like
really hard you essentially have to do a
full binary tree so the depth would also
be n as in the case of and but now the
size is 2 to the n
and here's indexing uh where you have
like uh R bits of addressing so if you
look at the you know the first up to
depth are you're actually finding out
what exactly is the addressing uh the
set of orbits are pointing to and then
you read accordingly and output the bit
okay so this would give you depth R plus
1 size 2 to the r plus one now if I is
small size is still small compared to n
okay so I'll I've defined now depth and
size informally I won't go into uh more
uh formal definition
okay and uh here's a question that
that's an interesting promise problem
randomized we're looking at randomized
decision tree for the following promise
problem where we want to find one
so you you look at the string and you're
promised that at least half of these
bits are one and you have to find a
particular index which is set to one
okay so that's the find one function and
so it's quite easy to see that if you
have access to Randomness and all you
are required to Output is a valid index
which has a one then it's very simple
you just randomly sample an index okay
an output if it has a one otherwise you
repeat it a few times and if you were
promised that there are at least half
half the bits or ones within 10 tries or
some you know you will be reasonably
sure to find a one okay and you will
give a a valid answer
but there's a problem with this
algorithm in the sense that it's not
repetitive right uh oh sorry okay
and the other thing to see is that you
know if you were to do on the other hand
a deterministic algorithm then it's easy
to see that you will require Omega n
many queries because you could just keep
answering zero until you have checked
for half the bits okay so this is this
is very easy super easy for randomized
heart for deterministic
uh the problem with this randomized
algorithm on the other hand is that with
overwhelming probability if you run this
yeah you won't get the same answer
right I mean you will have the answers
very uniformly distributed your index
and so what what is uh what what is
desirable what would be nice is if you
have a randomized algorithm that has
this access to Randomness as before but
is able to give one fixed answer for
with high probability for a fixed input
and this is what I would call is a
pseudo deterministic algorithm this was
defined first if I am not wrong by Gart
and goldwasser in 2011 and this is a
beautiful concept which has got many
applications recently
so this is what uh and because I'm
defining it in the context of query
algorithms you could Define in the
context of other algorithms as well so
for example I think Rahul and ego or
have a paper which shows that primes can
be found pseudo deterministically with
some exponential time between a number n
and it's twice but we don't know of a
deterministic algorithm
so this pseudogenistic concept has uh is
is really nice because it asks for this
non-repid the non-repetitive behavior
that you have for normal randomized
algorithm it tries to suppress that and
wants something repetitive and still
gives you the power of Randomness
hopefully so the question is you know
for pseudo deterministic algorithms
what's the uh what's the complexity
for the same problem
and this is what the gips paper proves
is Omega rooted
now let's look at so the so the the as I
said we find one problem is not a total
problem it's a promise problem
the main uh building block of this paper
was to look at the total uh search
problem which was this random CNF
formula fi that I spoke about yeah so
you get a random formula 5 with order
one width and then you have the search
version of this problem search Phi
hmm
so you have to Output any one Clause
that's falsified by the assignment X
and the randomized algorithms is more or
less the same you sample a random clause
and you output it if it's falsified and
you know these Clauses most of your
Clauses would be falsified so the same
algorithm works
essentially and
the main work parts of the gyps argument
is to show that this particular search
problem is uh going to require Omega
Rootin cost in the pseudo deterministic
setting
um
Okay so
how do they prove this and the proof is
surprisingly indirect it uses a lot of
Machinery in particular it uses new
standards degree lower bounds for
refutations of these formulas Phi
and then it uses a very interesting new
ingredient the recent breakthrough
result of Huang on the sensitivity
conjecture which is now a Huang
sensitivity theorem so it's a pretty
sophisticated argument
which sort of goes brings together a few
things as this characteristic of many of
Tony's work and and then it gets this
result Omega rooted
what we would like to do as they are the
pose is to lift this to the
communication setting
yeah so this now when I have a
superscript cc I mean the analogous
thing so for in the communication
setting PD would mean pseudo
deterministic
so same thing so we we would like to
prove if possible that this is hard
still the search Problem
or at least if you lift the formula in a
suitable way with a gadget like indexing
the corresponding search problem uh is
still hard for suitable difference
now this in this Workshop it might seem
that well why not use one of the lifting
theorems that you have right
the trouble is you know a pseudo
deterministic solution
of Phi composed with indexing may not
yield a solution for five
yeah and so you know uh we don't know
the the the the available lifting
theorems don't work
like that is always the same solution it
might not always in the same solution so
you can't extract solution for Phi uh
given a solution for yeah
um
Okay so
that's the reason as I said we looked at
intermediate models or and
and or and decision trees so these are
you know these are decision trees where
just as in ordinary decision trees uh
you query but each query now you can use
more well exotic functions like or or
and
and uh in one shot so they're sort of
touching they have this uh a flavor of
communication because an or query is
going to touch it's not localized it's
going to touch all your input variables
at one go right much like what Alice
would do when she communicates she comes
she evaluates a certain function which
is a function of all our input bits so
in the same way an or or an and query
would touch all the bits and likewise
parity
well the first observation is that well
if you allow or queries then even
deterministically find one is easy
because you could do a binary search
okay
and when if you look at parity decision
trees then you can show that
deterministically it's hard but pseudo
deterministically it's easy because you
can Implement an R by using Rand using
using randomized decision trees and now
you can do the binary search to find the
first one
and that will give you a pseudo
deterministic algorithm
it's also uh interesting that I'll have
more to say towards the end uh you know
this is really an interesting model
because this is sort of the first model
that where Randomness and determinism
are different
just as in communication complexity this
is the one of the most primitive models
where Randomness and determinism are
different even for computing Boolean
functions
okay so these two things show that not
quite the same tools can work yeah we
have to we have to find some analog of
what uh Tony and co-authors did to to to
adapt uh in in the in this context
we tried a lot but it didn't work we
don't know how to how to adapt that
argument as I said there have been many
moving Parts in that argument
so you know we decided to circumvent
algebra okay and well
this if you look at you know when the
function when the range of a function is
just 2 then it's normal Boolean function
and then pseudo determinism exactly
corresponds to Randomness and then there
is this classic result of Nissan from 89
which says that well Randomness is not
of much help
right so if you look at decision trees
uh ordinary decision trees now I'm
talking then the deterministic decision
tree complexity is always upper bounded
by the cube of the randomized complexity
right
so
and
if you dig more into the proof of this
then you see actually that you can adapt
a Nissan's argument to multi-output
functions as well
yeah there's nothing much going on about
uh you know this function being a
Boolean function it would just work for
multiple output functions as well the
same relationship
okay
but if that works in the same way then
you know what does a what does a pseudo
deterministic solution do a pseudo
deterministic solution is offering a
solution so it's actually Computing a
multi-output function as a randomized
process with high probability
right and if you just put these two
arguments together
um sorry yeah I mean this this
observation I I forgot mentioning so
this is not completely novel to us this
observation that Nissan's argument
continues to work in the context of
multi-output functions was sort of
implicit with a slightly weaker version
in uh I think this is gold right
goldmaster and Ron
yeah they also observe this uh
previously
but it's a slightly uh weaker uh version
because they have a log dependency on
the on the range of the output and we we
can get rid of that by just you know
being a little bit more careful
in larger range yes larger range
let's say in the search problem zero one
to M where n is the number of clauses
foreign
observation is that this continues to
work no matter what the range is and now
if you put these two ideas together you
can see that you know in fact in the
ordinary decision tree model pseudo
determinism for search problems doesn't
buy you much uh when compared to
deterministic algorithms
okay so you know the same relationship
you just replace the R by the pseudo
domestic here in in and this goes
through
and this would immediately give you an N
to the one-third lower bound on this
search Problem
because we know the search File provides
a random formula because we know that
deterministically it's very hard
Omega n and this would give us n to the
one third
so that entire Machinery if we were
willing to settle for n to the one third
can be avoided by just making this
connection which is to say that pseudo
determinism and determinism in the two
models are the same up to a poly-factor
block
no it's still not longer than it's
Tuesday yeah two is the best lower bound
and uh even here it's not known where
the tree is dead
this hasn't moved since Nissan's time
I think we expect it to be quadratic
I don't know what yeah well
everybody will agree that we expected
people
okay so you know having
that this was encouraging and then we
thought okay maybe we can try to do the
same thing for hand or decision trees
yeah
or you know this more exotic decision
trees
um
so can we de-randomize this uh this
decision tree algorithms because just as
we saw before the starting point of
those argument was in the simple Boolean
function case and then we could use
answer argument now we are talking about
this more exotic decision trees which
have these acts which give you access to
and queries or and or queries or these
parity queries yeah and the same so the
analogous question is pretty clear
right right
you're paying attention so you it of
course won't work for parody this is
false right but what about these two
and at this point uh an interesting
thing happened which is that we found
out yogesh found out that you know there
were four other people who had asked the
same question as this one
uh at least the first one from a
different uh context uh this is if I'm
not wrong this is Alexander Nob Shahar
Lovett McGuire anyone yeah and they
their motivation was very different they
were trying to prove lifting theorems
for uh you know when you lift with the
and Gadget
okay so their motivation was
communication complexity as well but to
prove lifting theorems another area
where Tony has had a great influence so
both these Works were influenced by
Tony's work
but we sort of came to it from a
slightly different point of view and
in fact that maybe we were sort of I
mean you know they used more algebraic
ideas and they were trying to solve this
problem algebraically whereas we are
trying to use more combinatorial uh
methods
so the first observation we had was you
know you could make it even simpler you
could ask the same question about
ordinary decision I mean you can you can
reduce the question about and or query
complexity to a question about ordinary
decision trees
and as I said before somehow depth is
has been more studied in decision tree
and size less but you just look at this
simple connection this shows that you
know the the and or query complexity is
sandwiched between law of the size
yeah and this is not hard to see this is
obvious in this one you know just look
at the first uh thing that I showed you
know an and uh
and and or therefore as well has a very
skinny decision tree where the size is
not large
okay so just these two facts give you
the the very nice thing that you know if
you can sort of de-randomize size you're
done
of ordinary decision trees
so this is the depth derandomization and
then we thought that well I'm sure we're
thinking that you know Noam or somebody
else must have uh looked up at decision
tree science
and it was very surprising that this
question was never asked this was talked
about in the literature in uh
in in in sort of implicit fashion
um saying that there could be some size
savings but nobody asked this question
can can it be de-andomized
so this was an unaddressed question
and uh in another work at this point
what happened was my student nikhil
mande was working on some other problems
and he came up and asked a question and
it turned out that his question and this
question was very closely connected he
was working with ranks of decision trees
something to do with learning theory and
you can again look at ranks
essentially as a question about size so
every question the two questions sort of
converged on understanding the role of
Randomness with respect to size
Okay so
foreign
's classic argument
just a little bit
so
Nissan in particular showed the
following thing right which is a
beautiful combinatorial characterization
of query complexity he showed that the
block sensitivity is the right
combinatorial quantity to look at
because
deterministic randomized they're all
sandwiched between these things
right and this was very influential as
you know block sensitivity the the most
important contribution I feel of the
work was to introduce this concept of
block sensitivity okay and this is a
very this has been a very influential
notion
but
for our problem
sensitivity just doesn't work because if
you look at the and function or the or
function the block sensitivity is n
because if you look at or at the all
zero input every input is completely
sends it
right and
so
this I mean even though these functions
have very large blocks and as large as
it gets their sizes are very small
right so you can have functions with
very large block sensitivity but still
small size right so this as it is block
sensitivity is is not going to work
so what we do or we thought at that
moment at that point was well let's look
at an after you know trying it out
various things we thought that this is
an interesting new notion let's look at
sort of the counting analog of block
sensitivity which is uh what we call the
block number of a function which is the
number of minimal sensitive blocks of a
function at point x is its you know
sharp BS
okay and then just as in the case of
Nissan we will maximize it over all X
and that will give you yes so here's the
difference is these minimal sensitive
blocks don't have to be destroyed yes
you go through all all of them
yeah and this will become clear here
because you know uh so let's let's see
some examples so for or it's always at
most n just the same as block
sensitivity
same for n but if you look at majority
now it is very large because if you look
at majority at the all zero input there
are many overlapping sensitive blocks in
particular there are exactly n choose n
over two minimally sensitive blocks
right so this could be exponentially
large
and uh
well it turns out later we learned that
this was not a completely new notion uh
abhisha tal and Kulkarni in 2016 had
used the same notion they called it by a
different name but in a different
context
hmm okay so uh
to summarize what we found out was this
is very helpful to look at the Block uh
the block number with yogesh nikhil J
Kumar and swagato what we were able to
prove is this is very reminiscent of
Nissan's bound we get law of the
randomized size is at least below the if
there was no login this would be exactly
the analog of Nissan but we get an extra
log n and if you want to talk about it
we can talk offline this login cannot be
avoided
and then on the upper bound side as well
we can we do not get again as clean a
result as Nissan got it because you know
you involve this combinatorial quantity
but you also involved
randomized size again uh you cannot
avoid this uh because if you I I can say
that offline I'm consuming time uh
but you can because of this being lower
bounded by that you can patch it up nice
so here I'm I'm using the fact that our
size is lower bounded by log accountable
okay
so
yes there is D side remember
oh yeah you should read it this is like
a chain yeah
Okay so
yeah this worked out
and then by the previous observation you
could use similar ideas that we had uh
before to say that now we can work on on
search problems as well okay and so we
can show that you know the same thing
this is jointly with Mina and yogesh
that for every total search problem now
the size
when you're dealing with size it doesn't
matter the you know deterministic size
log of deterministic size and log of
pseudo deterministic size for total
search problems are polynomial related
up to this log nose
factors
and this I think gives a one interesting
immediate consequence of this is that
following which I think
was not known is the following if you
have a random CNF order order one width
formula and you look at its search
problem then you can this just shows
that the pseudo deterministic size of
the search file problem is going to be
exponentially large
I think in the gyps paper what they
showed was that if this was to be lifted
by xor then this would be large but the
unlifted formula as far as I know it was
not known
so uh is that right
and this we get for free because you
know uh we know that the deterministic
size is large so pseudodiversity has to
be large because silver domestic and
deterministic are
polynomial related
and uh
you know you can now as I said you can
just uh because you've got a bound on
size you can use it to bound all these
exotic models yeah and well this one I'm
lying a bit this requires a bit of more
work
uh because you know the short answer is
because and decision trees cannot
balance themselves if you were asking
monotone and queries they cannot balance
themselves whereas ore and decision
trees can balance them so you get if you
get a ordinary decision tree size lower
bound it immediately needs a lower Bound
for this for for Android decision trees
but for just and decision trees you have
to work a bit more
because they don't balance so it's not
clear how to get it how to go from size
directly
okay but this can be done
and now once you do that and you use our
trick uh from before you can also say
the same thing for search problems if
you have paid attention carefully you
know this exponent keeps going up in the
search problems and that's because to
absorb the range foreign
because now we get this now we can
separate
or random formulas would be a separation
between randomized and solutions
okay so this gives us the separation for
intermediate models of and or decision
trees
and there are many open problems to work
uh some of the open problems my favorite
one is parity decision trees because
this is the first model as I said where
Randomness and determinism are different
the easiest model yeah yet it seems very
hard I mean maybe we are being dumb but
it seems we have no idea well
communication complexity seems a little
farther out even because if we can't
show it for parity decision trees then
it seems the communication complexities
and more and there are many other
problems uh I can talk about if you're
interested to offline is
okay to conclude
you know Tony gave me lots of good
advice from 2009 to 2012 when I was a
postdoc I had a really great time there
she told me several times at that point
to learn Raz McKenzie I kept on ignoring
that she asked me to learn proof
complexity I never learned it but now
I'm all of a sudden very interested
because of this search version of it I
wish I
then hit your advice
well I was interested in my own problems
mostly with meta problems so therefore
we ended up writing
a paper titled a little advice can be
very helpful
with Jeff and faith that was lots of fun
happy birthday
[Applause]
thank you any uh questions
yeah can you say say some of the things
about dag size
that would be interesting
that I that that thought came to me when
I Was preparing myself I haven't thought
about it
it'll be interesting
yeah so uh your simulation is is there
precise is
simulation right is there any hope of
getting a polynomial
or you mean because of the log yeah uh
I think there is a counter example uh
the top of my head I I'm not able to
recall but I don't think you can do that
okay this is the best one can hope for
yeah what about shaving off the login
fact oh you said the login factor in the
lower bound was tight what about the
upper Bell out because you like a lot
cubed in
yeah
no no so the lock Cube n in the upper
bound
this one right I mean well yeah I mean
yeah well this lock Cuban appears
because of the I mean one of the okay
you might be able to reduce this
exponent uh to log of n but I I don't
think you can reduce it I mean you can
get rid of that
this is not possible
for example look at the threshold 2
function
we can talk offline with the threshold
two function you know it requires
deterministic communication
deterministic query complexity log of N
and randomized uh one oh I see I see
order one I see yeah yeah sure okay
more questions all right yeah
do you have some examples of
you know
I think there's a quantum
but for parity decision trees if you
consider that to be non-trivial it's
yeah otherwise no
more questions
all right let's thank Our God again
[Applause]